évidemment il ya quelque chose de ce
grenier peut-être même d' anachronique à
vous parler de la loi de règlement de la
crise naissent dans les choses ont
changé je donnerai quelques beaux
d'ailleurs et quelques chiffres ont
montré les points les températures
ambiantes ont changé entre 2010 et 2020
mais il nous semble cependant d'abord
parce que le respect de cette présidence
auditionné mais parce que le sénat comme
l'assemblée auront à débattre puis à
côté l'espérant la loi donnait des
règlements il ne semble cependant que
cet exercice est peut-être est
nécessaire tant pour le contrôle de
l'action gouvernementale si peut-être
pour enrichir notre réflexion pour
l'avenir
pourquoi les gens sont si différents par
rapport à 2010 9 en deux exemples
l'activité partielle le chômage partiel
dans l'année 2010 nice était à peu près
100 millions d'euros un petit peu moi
aujourd'hui nous obtenions gain de 6
milliards d'euros aux deux des ports ce
public et seulement pour cinquième mois
de l'année des minimes 1 re n'est pas du
tout dans la même température de l'eau
qui le lie les recettes fiscales
vous aurez constaté que voter contre
elle même voie que nous sommes passés à
281 et 3 milliard de recettes et les
rues milliards de recettes plus que ce
que je dresse comptait y compris d'un
air rectification de finances la vision
on a eu deux milliards de plus connu ni
fille et fils ont rapporté à peu près 3
milliards supplémentaires et donc nous
avions on peut constater en 2010 9
milliards de plus de recettes s'est
passé avec et sans doute le meilleur
recouvrement d'impôts de l'as rome le
cyclisme économique alors que nous
constatons vous du saké mois de l'année
ne nie pas comme sommes et dans les airs
de l'autre les choses ont un peu changé
mais pas des daims et chiffres à 43
milliards de recettes en moins par
rapport à l' aider vivoter voilà
quelques mois donc nulle part lui
milliards de recettes en plus sur une
année et d'autre part 43 milliards de
recettes en moins dans les cinq premiers
mois comme le chômage partiel en anglais
quelques choses sont très différentes et
sont difficilement comparables
cependant il devrait d'abord revenir sur
cet exercice 2009 pour souligner et
c'est le rôle de ne pas glisser le puck
liste de le fermer
quelconque la soul elle même d'abord que
nous avons assaini les comptes publics
si nous prenons les trois traverse
exercice budgétaire et de commençons à
voir un recul de nécessaire et possible
de terre savatan effectivement au 31
décembre de l'année
lorsque je suis arrivé dans les
spécialités sous l'autorité du premier
ministre et du président de la
république
elle prend des comptes avait évoqué un
déficit de 3 4% au mois de mai 2010 m
je rappelle qu'il était de 2 9% à la fin
de l'exercice 2010 est à des mesures qui
nous ont parfois été reproché de
l'économie de la ville 3% en 2008 et
donc 200 en 2019 avec les faits doivent
aussi c'est une à trois pour cent jours
à valère que ces chiffres sont très
largement déstocké noms évoqués et de ce
que le sénat afin de raconter en général
allant de la bière avait également
évoqué un désaveu
nous n'arrivons pas à tenir d'autant qu'
il fallait bien constaté à la fin
relativement ordis normal passant ce qui
était constatée partout en europe et
notamment en france comme si c'était ma
meilleure et surtout que cette année
2010 a été marqué a lancé que miss des
comptes publics est donc notre
commission à lui à connaître d'un budget
veut des modifier les scream ensuite en
revendications notamment des défilés je
ne vous annoncerai par exemple à l'appui
colonna du grand débat et malgré ces
milliards d'euros de recettes en moins
ou de dépenses en plus supplémentaires
nous avons tenu des comptes sans budget
rectificatif en tenant le milliard
d'euros et en ayant il n'aura vont
baisser de aval ou trois points en trois
exercices budgétaires
nous avons aussi fait de la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale et le meilleur
recouvrement de l'impôt des objectifs
qui nous ont pas mis le post abc news
recette puisque je rappelle aussi les
recettes ont augmenté les taux d'impôts
diminué
c'est le cas de la taxe d'habitation
c'est le cas bien sûr de l'impôt sur les
sociétés sept cas la réforme de la
fiscalité du patrimoine et celui
qu'offre c'est ce qu'alain j'ai eu
l'occasion de vider d'ailleurs très
inspiré par les travaux du sénat et je
le remercie et je crois que
un nom bien ensemble sur ces questions
façon d'un consensus politique assez
affirmée soit continuer les tuera le
faire mais également par mail info
c'est notamment le cas de l'impôt à la
source puisque la ligue 1 3 milliard de
recettes supplémentaires est notamment
due aux milliards encombrement de
l'impôt sur le revenu la cour des
comptes a salué elle même la sincérité
et la qualité des courses présentées par
l'état même si la plume et nous pouvons
que nous associons être réalisée au plus
qu'il faut que ça son célèbre des
comptes évoqué la complexité de notre
fiscalité et de nos comptes par des
taxes affectées de plus en plus
nombreuses par les dépenses fiscales
importantes et par des dispositions
dérogatoires de plus en plus compliqués
qui nuisent aux principes d'unité
budgétaire le savez que ce n'est pas le
ministre des comptes publics qui tend à
vis à vis de ses collègues et parfois il
faut qu'ils achètent et son pouvoir
manifestement tant vis-à-vis du
parlement regrette les créations de
dépenses le cristal de taxes affectées
qui vient nuire à la sincérité et à la
simplicité des comptes et surtout au
fait que ce budget soit surtout saccades
règlement qu'avec de valider la
stratégie économique au fiscale du
présent d'arrêter l'épidémie simple
puisque juste avant les éléments du gobi
d'auge à graver en lettres
même avec un peu de mauvaise foi qui
n'est pas la responsabilité directe du
président de la république de plus que
c'est évidemment quelque chose de tel
dans le monde entier
nous avions le chômage les plus bas
depuis vingt ans de plus grande création
d'emplois notamment industrielles dans
les territoires les plus touchés je
pense notamment aux liens donnant
naissance au plus grand nombre de
créations d'entreprises depuis vingt ans
la meilleure croissance par rapport à
nos voisins une consommation qui
repartaient à la hausse et des baisses
d'impôt qui étaient constatés notamment
sur le secteur du capital et de
l'entreprise
cependant ces baisses d'impôts n'ont pas
fait naître de baisse de recettes
il ya nos confrères la courbe de laffer
vérification cdma l'encouragement la
valeur travail et d'encouragement à la
300 entreprises que l'on peut avoir plus
de recettes cotisations sociales dues
par recettes fiscales entreprises comme
le salariat notre part
quelques nous permettre par ailleurs de
continuer à baisser les impôts ou en
diminuant et biens mobiliers poids de la
première semaine les choses ducobu 19
mai que les chiffres donnés sur la
condition de la dette pour la première
fois était et c'est important puisque la
dette abaissée par 2019 constatée par
l'insee et par la cour des comptes et
donc c'est ce cercle vertueux qui doit
nous inspirer pour le futur de ce point
de vue le gouvernement et singulièrement
ceux de le pensons avec l'eau de mer
c'est que en aucun cas la création d'un
monument ou l'augmentation des
fiscalités ne doit être la solution à la
difficulté économique que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui est que si nous
avons fait le choix de la dette qui a
évidemment des sujets préoccupants
niveaux de déficit et dette publics
ce n'est pas par la création d'impôts
que nous allons résoudre ses difficultés
budgétaires mais il n'y a pas un
encouragement à la croissance à
l'investissement et à la consommation
elle ne peut pas être dépréciées par des
gels anti économique dans tout cas
l'accord finalement extraits de
continuer à maintenir des baisses
d'impôts et pourquoi pas à proposer aux
autres si le clovis de 19 ans n'était
pas la prod ont désormais une utopie
peut-être maintenant le micro ni puisque
évidemment il a et d'orienter décision
est politique sans doute soyons
nous-mêmes ce président en train de
commenter les bronchites d'ornement et
peut-être même dans l'est où le clézio
félicité de cela on trouve évidemment
mais je vous vois sourire à sauver le
politique est amicale mais bien sûr la
lune règlement n'est déjà pas mal amusé
du débat public
d'ordinaire elle ne l'est encore moi
aujourd'hui puisqu'il s'agit pas de
commenter les chiffres des ministères et
d'imaginer ce que sera la fin d'année
denis pain mais le gouvernement
considère que c'est avec des comptes qui
était plus un scénic il a pu continuer à
emprunter et à voir la démarche des
soutiens économiques les salarial
important qu'il a eus ces ballets
recevait terminer monsieur le président
pour mon mercier dénomination diriger
effectivement un effort très important a
été fait et j'en remercie également
présents d'abord n'y a aucune honte pour
ces dix quinze jours plus tôt que
d'habitude cette voie de règlement qui
doit je l'espère plus de temps au
parlement pour la travailler
interrogé
peut-être que la deuxième marche parce
que le croiseur et des finances adji
c'est que le rapporteur général comme je
sais que d'exhorter le rang saint martin
le son du côté de l'assemblée nationale
et d'utiliser effectivement cette loi de
règlement encore plus que les 80 ans de
discussions parce que l'exécution des
gongs a autant d'importance en doute les
inscriptions budgétaires de fin d'année
et c'est sans doute ce qui rencontre
encore plus ce poids du parlement et qui
permet à l'exécutif de mieux travailler
puisqu'il a devant lui des
parlementaires soucieux des chiffres et
de leur voies d'exécution à sa série des
jantes alu d'arrêt pour vous dire que
j'ai tenu ma promesse
en trois années le budget terme sur les
finances aucun décret d'avancé n'a été
pris en 2019 et le parlement a été
respecté dans son autorisation
parlementaire
c'est la deuxième fois en quasiment 45
de cette procédure de jetair existe et
deux fois vous n'avez pas eu d'excès
valence les deux années pleines à tunis
des copies
merci monsieur le ministre
alors puisque comme cela a déjà été
mentionné à deux reprises il n'est pas
impossible qu'un certain nombre de
membres de notre commission ne soient
tentés de venir dans leur questionnement
vers la situation de l'exercice 2020
plus que sur un regard rétrospectif
strictement limitée à l'année 2010 19 je
vais faire exception en maintenant pour
ce qui me concerne c'est pour ça que je
maintiens la tradition de poser les
questions en premier je vais pour ma
part m'en tenir assez strictement à un
regard sur l'exécution 2019
mais évidemment on vous interrogeant sur
des aspects qui peuvent se poursuivre au
fur et à mesure de la succession des
exercices budgétaires
dans son rapport sur les exécutions 2019
la cour des comptes renouvelle ses
critiques contre les techniques de
débugage et isation notamment par les
fonds sans personnalité juridique
contrôlée par l'état dont les comptes ne
sont jamais présentés au parlement
c'est tout particulièrement le cas du
fonds aux l'innovation dans l'industrie
alimenté par des dividendes ce fonds n'a
pas réellement de ressources
sanctuarisés d'autant que devraient s'y
substituer en quelque sorte des recettes
provenant de la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris
laquelle a été mieux que reporter cir
est autant qu'on puisse le juger de
façon absolument définitive sir est
[Musique]
abandonnée en tirerez vous les
conséquences dans le projet de loi de
finances pour 2021
en supprimant tout simplement ce fonds
pour construire au sein du budget
général
peut-être une mission budgétaire ou un
autre véhicule plus efficace afin de
porter les crédits nécessaires à la
relance de notre économie puisque ses
moyens j'irai sont orientés vers un
soutien direct à l'économie deuxième
question la fiscalité affectée elle
aussi d'une certaine façon elle est un
moyen assez fréquent de contourner les
contraintes de l'autorisation budgétaire
est une forme 2d budgétisation le
plafonnement des recettes au profit du
budget de l'état est par ailleurs
souvent mal compris les organismes aux
taxes et estimant que leur contribution
doit être utilisée conformément à leur
objet et que sinon elle n'a pas lieu
d'être
souscrivez-vous à la recommandation là
encore de la corée conde de mieux
encadrer la fiscalité affectés et ferez
vous de nouvelles propositions dans ce
domaine
enfin troisième question toujours sur
l'exercice 2010 9
il est marqué par la suppression de la
comptabilité d' analyse des coûts qui
contribuerait à donner une vision plus
complète des coûts d'une politique en
présentant notamment les déversements
entre mission lorsque cette comptabilité
d' analyse des coûts a été supprimée par
un décret en octobre 2018
elle devait être remplacée par une
comptabilité analytique
remplissant des objectifs finalement
assez similaire où on est ce projet de
mise en place d'une comptabilité
analytique de l'état et au delà de
l'expérimentation qui en est faite
je vis nous donner des informations sur
la généralisation de ce dispositif
voilà merci monsieur le ministre de
répondre à ces questions mais peut-être
avant de vous donner la parole nous
allons entendre notre collègue albéric
de montgolfier rapporteur général du
budget pour ses propres questions
albéric merci ça va réserver ce monsieur
ministre bonjour je meurs collègues qui
m'entendent est également je salue et je
vais me borner à poser des questions sur
le règlement de loi de règlement puisque
je pense que certain nombre de collègues
seront tentés de poser des questions sur
ce début d'année à 5 juillet 2020 j'en
ai tout simplement une question si vous
avez un élément de précisions quant à un
éventuel plfr puisque vous êtes réjouir
l'instant que comme moi je je m'en
réjouis également qu'il n'y ait pas eu
de décret d'avancé qu'il n'y ait pas eu
de paix les ferons condamner de l'année
précédente
bon c'était malheureusement une
réjouissance de courte durée puisque
nous sommes déjà au 2e pelley faire dans
les circonstances l'exigent
évidemment le contestera pas mais quand
je vois par b le la nécessité d'adapter
un stand de dispositifs quand on voit
les chiffres également sur le chômage
partiel même si on arrive j'espère une
stagnation ou un début de décrue sur le
chômage partiel artois l'activité on
s'aperçoit que nous aurons besoin soit
parlé de la relance de d'actualiser
présente deux chiffres voilà c'est ça ma
sera seule question si vous aviez des
éléments de calendrier faut-il
s'attendre en juin apple fr et sera qui
consacre exclusivement à l'ajustement
des dispositifs actuels au leadership
nouveau ou sera-t-il consacrée également
d'ores et déjà des éléments de de
relance si je me borne à l'exécution les
lois de règlement vous êtes très joué
monsieur ministre de la bonne tenue des
comptes
on peut avoir une vision peut-être un
peu différentes et pas forcément se
retrouver
il ya sans doute un élément
qui rend les choses plus objectif c'est
la comparaison avec nos voisins et cie
ont probablement l'endettement on
s'aperçoit très concrètement que depuis
les autres pays ont choisi de diminuer
se sont donné les moyens de diminuer
leur endettement celui-ci a baissé ce
nos voisins de 5 points de pib depuis
2010 est alors que l'endettement en
france continue à augmenter ou du moins
il reste d'un niveau extrêmement élevé
98 l'important dans la loi de règlement
98 avec une important donc on nous avons
choisi par rapport à l'ensemble des
états veut nos voisins y compris
l'europe du sud jamais peut-être à part
l'italie
très concrètement une situation et un
recours au déficit et à l'endettement
là où les autres ont choisi des
stratégies d désendettement ce qui
aujourd'hui si je crois l'allemagne
donnent plus de marge de manoeuvre
l'allemagne avec une situation
budgétaire et son endettement beaucoup
plus favorable que la france dans la
crise que nous connaissons
malheureusement l'allemagne a beaucoup
plus de marge de manoeuvre que la france
c'est ce que je disais chaque année en
dix ans en cas d'accident
le site est un choc pétrolier c'est
peut-être le contraire qui s'est produit
donc fait modeste dans la prévision en
cas de krach boursier ça s'est aussi
produit est bien la france aurait moins
de marge de manoeuvre que ses voisins
donc la question est très simple
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas
aujourd'hui ce choix ce choix je
reprends la situation de bénédicte que
christine lagarde avait reprise au fmi
est ce que la france ne peut pas
regretter de ne pas avoir réparer la
toiture pendant que le soleil brillait
voilà est-ce qu'on n'a pas un peu trop
profité de la bonne tenue des recettes
de l'élasticité fort des recettes pour
ne pas faire les efforts et aujourd'hui
on a des choix qui divergent
j'ai deux questions maintenant plus
précise concernant les dépenses et
l'exécution qui concerne d'abord le
ministère de l'intérieur et le ministère
de l'outre-mer
puisque ce sont deux ministères où l'on
constate une croissance relativement
significative de la masse salariale +3 %
donc comment l'expliquer on a su
reprendre ministère l'intérieur
plus de 150 millions d'euros par rapport
à ce qui était votée en et les fit donc
un écart significatif
est-ce que vous avez des éléments pour
expliquer cet écart risque par exemple
des primes ont été versées à des forces
de sécurité qu'est ce qui explique en
effet d'avoir plus d'un pour cent par
rapport à ce qui était prévu en terme de
masse salariale sur le mystère des
tailleurs eux au contraire j'ai prenait
l'exemple dans l'autre sens
concernant plutôt une moindre exécution
sous d'exécution mais là qui est tout à
fait significative ça concerne le plan
france très haut débit parce que pour le
flanc prend enfance très haut débit on a
une exécution qui est très très en
dessous de ce qui avait été budgété
initialement
je reconnais en termes de crédits de
paiement à moins de 20% de ce qui était
prévu
donc c'était exactement 18 en est à 18 4
% de consommation en termes de crédits
de paiement
je rappelle que ce fonds qui est
destinée la cité numérique
je crois que la situation actuelle nous
a montré la nécessité du télétravail
c'étaient les cités du téléenseignement
y compris dans votre ministère mais ses
ministres y compris à des défis panda
auditionnés et qui dit à la fois les les
ambitions mais également les difficultés
pratiques qu'il y avait à mettre en
place le télétravail
ainsi la continuité du service a été
terne est mal assuré y compris au sénat
mais dans l'ensemble des entreprises
nous avons besoin d'avoir un équipement
en très haut débit et ça s'est dotée
notamment par cette mission et on on
peut regretter ou s'étonner de la très
faible consommation des crédits jeudi 18
4% des crédits de paiement qui ont été
consommés par rapport la transition
militaire
voilà je pense que c'est une nécessité
qui était évidente mais qui apparaît
encore plus flagrante avec le
télétravail est ce qu'ils sont que nous
connaissons voilà donc je me bornerai à
ces trois questions pour laisser la
place aux collègues
quid de la situation de la dette regrets
ou pas et comment expliquer nos
divergences à par rapport à nos voisins
crédits du ministère intérieur et crédit
france 3 10 merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
monsieur le ministre ce qu'on peut vous
demander de réagir déjà ses premières
séries de questions tout à fait à ce
président alors pour vous pouvez pas
pour les questions sur la critique de
daisy budgétisation bon de rester dans
mon introduction je les fais miennes
vous avez des questions plus pratiques
assure le fonds d'innovation
la question qui se pose le déneigement
de la française des jeux et surtout la
question de l'aéroport de paris qui est
le manque de recettes que vous évoquez
ce fonds faut-il de religiosité ne sais
pas moi qui vais vous donner la table
locatif mais il appartient misé
l'économie et des finances je sais qui
s'est engagé notamment à ma réponse à
écouter compte à améliorer les choses
pour 2021 fortement notamment avec
l'épaisseur du plan bâti et je crois que
cette propre effectivement vise
l'économique de thouars présenté sa
stratégie sur un sujet qui donc vous
n'avez pas renié l'importance des
critiques et la forme
qu'est-ce qu'il s'agira toujours d'un
fonds halle aux grains secs et ses
recettes sont elles toujours celle qu'on
attend la parole aux dividendes on voit
ce que sont est ce qu'elles doivent être
heureux budgétisé dans une mission
particulière avec le sujet que ce fonds
est financé également le pays a donc qui
est également quelque chose qui est en
dehors la médiatisation actuelle donc le
miz économie et des finances qui est le
coordonnateur de ces fonds qui l'avait
même de répondre aux critiques de la
cour et et à la côte et je sais pour
2020 il y aura des modifications sur la
fidélité à quelques mois je partage
votre sujet le président et ce n'est pas
moi qui pèche le plus parfois même le
parlement il lui arrive chez les
attaques ad hominem veille
on peut le partager sous prétexte
d'ailleurs que la fiscalité affecté
pédagogique
ce n'est pas du tout évident on pas
l'occasion d'en parler ici bien sûr et
elle veut pas affecter tout des crédits
par rapport à 0,7 ce qui évidemment ce
nom on ne pourrait pas avoir comme
dépense de sport
sport la culture la culture écologique
d'écologie ou les polluants et peu
évidemment personne n'est là pour payer
l'éducation nationale ou le ministre des
armées sur les enfants et moi sur les
soldats mais cette fiscalité accepté est
là et les parfois un réflexe de
pédagogie qu'on peut comprendre devant
la critique d'un pauvre la complexité
des choses mais je ne crois pas qu'elle
soit la bonne solution
faut-il mieux les encadrer il faut même
parfois les supprimer le seul président
nous avons proposé depuis 2002 cet été
puis déplaît beaucoup de petites actions
nous avons revu d'utiliser et nous avons
supprimé ces axes parfois c'est
contribution volontaire obligatoire
parce que c'est une nouveauté lexical
qui est inventé
finalement le des finances publiques et
donc voit bien que c'est pas facile
rappelez-vous des débats qui ont élu
soitec sur les farines maintenant il
pourrait démultiplier
on a supprimé beaucoup de petits textes
en les re budgétisant je pense que c'est
ce qu'il faudrait qu'il faut continuer à
faire en regardant des paumes comme ça
de 200 à 300 millions d'euros selon
notre bête évidemment plus les taudis
texte supprimé moyenne textes des
posters et avec les montants de plus en
plus important alors vous dites par
ailleurs que ses notes au moins compris
côté des plafonds et quand le circuit
retourne au budget d'état tout à fait
entendre enfin ça c'est possible du
tuyau est ce qu'il a été avancée pour
faire une dépense que ce qu'on doit
d'abord ans absolument ce poste pour
arriver de recettes si on fait ça c'est
sûr on ne reste pas sur les économies
dans notre pays on va continuer à dire
la dépense publique
vous n'allez pas posé la question mais
pour l'instant nous sommes à 61 % de
dépenses publiques
je ne crois qu on devrait avoir un petit
sourire évidemment cela moi je considère
aussi qu'avec cet acte et on s'aperçoit
que c'est dans un sens et pas dans
l'autre on a eu ce débat alors montré
gilet jaune a détruit ou la recette
avait à la fois au département sécurité
au caire
la fille qui est aux parlementaires et
de comprendre très bien les attachés de
la suite mais quand les radars se sont
effondrés là on a demandé au général
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous avons
c'est donc
l'autonomie de la taxe affectée
finalement quand y'a pas assez il
yal'état tout pensé que tu te trouves on
n'est pas pourtant qu'est la récupère et
par ailleurs le parlement n'a pas à
donner son avis puisque vous le savez
mais personne le grand pouvoir des
parlementaires c'est comme d'autoriser
les crédits est de donner un avis sur
les politiques publiques qui s'est
infectée
vous n'avez pas beaucoup d'amis à donner
et donc le miz les comptes publics lui
est très favorable au but utiliser un
maximum de qualité soit la suppression
d'une analyse des coûts j'entends votre
votre question le médecin des armées est
très précurseur aura sans doute
l'occasion de me planter un alors une
budget noté un de présenter des travaux
sur une analyse génétique avant de tenir
comme cela on aurait dû le généraliser
pour plusieurs ministères beaucoup
sensibilisé il faut bien avouer que
épisodes de koh vide
nous avons beaucoup aidé à le faire des
travaux vous rendre malade et le médecin
des armées a sans doute peu près pour
pouvoir vous présenter en mairie soit
cette thématique particulière avec
beaucoup de dépenses ont pu observer
cette analyse des coûts des politiques
pour le rapporteur général
alors ils se félicitent qui épate décret
d'avancé qui regrette que les bsr c'est
vrai et j'ai eu des progrès que le
touriste n'est pas une critique il
événements mais vaut mieux appeler faire
que des décades avance le plfr c'est une
discussion parlementaire il ya une
autorisation il y avait un moment il a
même parfois des compromis c'est le cas
pour les deux tiers et je remercie de
ces mâles sont de sa bio constructive de
l'urgence décidées par le gouvernement
n'a autorisé par lui mais c'est un menu
des décrets d'avancé on aurait plus et
pour tout vous dire son importance
général la tentation était grande de sa
dette externe ans franchement vous
n'aurez plus qu'à aller mettre en place
on a pensé qu'on espérait faire c'était
quand même mieux même si c'était pas
envie d'avancer de l'écologie nous
venons très fortement de notre immense
que de le faire sans autorisation
parlementaire explicite sur les éléments
de calendrier
nous pensons que nous aurons à préfère
trois ans très loin des publié dans le
niveau rouge et du conditionnel avec
on ne sera plus dans l'urgence à
quelques exceptions près peut-être de
correction et de climat le rapport à
fédéral nous pourrions dire que deux
premiers pv faire c'était durant ce qui
pour les mp3 et préfère la résilience
notamment lorsqu on devra accompagner un
peu de secteurs qui restent concernés
c'est pas du tourisme de ma gratte
s'annonce importante sa part le premier
ministre dans le thème dans l'honneur
dans le domaine des hôtels et
restaurants des producteurs le sport de
la culture et ce sont comme des secteurs
qui vont toujours connaître soit des
préconisations de sa voiture soit des
conditions très unitaire de nature
extrêmement difficile et donc il faudra
continuer à les aider ou la résidence et
j'ai pris un engagement on travaille
mesure collectivités locales dans ce
placard
et puis après il y aura le moment de la
relance et le troisième est là ce n'est
pas dans le plf crois que de métro le
plan de relance en tout cas ce n'est pas
comme ça que nous imaginons les choses
pour l'instant nous mettons dans le plfr
3 la mesure de résidence pourrait
d'éléments secteur nous avons évoqué
tout à leur donnera peut-être d'autres
et puis les rares moments de la relance
qui doit être évidemment moment de
grande concertation nationale apparaît
déconnecté le car et dont le choix pour
l'instant et c'est bien normal n'a pas
été encore c'est notamment parce que par
définition ne connaissons pas l'ampleur
de la crise signalons confinement quels
sont exactement des pertes en termes de
recettes et comment l'activité
économique de reprendre en sérieux mais
j'espère avoir un contenu rapporteur
général et revenir vers vous monsieur
présent comme je lé fais bravo mr
général de précision puisque nous allons
prochainement des réunions chez ne se
produise sur ce point sur leurs
vêtements et la question de ce que vous
regrettez pas finalement de la partie
russe d'économie bon je vous répondrai
avec les ici mais ce n'est pas mon rôle
jamais ici que vous et c'est là devant
la majorité sénatoriale aurait pu
encourager davantage
j'étais malheureusement parfois vous
même et traversy comme une prison la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale avait noté des économies quand
la majorité que le groupe ne doit pas
accepter en pas revenir sur la politique
du logement pardon à ceux des contrats
aidés on va regarder
c'est bizarre me reproche aujourd'hui
d'avoir fait c'est l'économie à part
convaincu que j'ai proposé jusqu'à
présent mais j'aurais d'hier ont
rapporté en général la comparaison sur
la tête avec les autres pays n'est pas
tout à fait juste parce que si notre
dette a beaucoup moins baissé que
d'autres c'est que nous l'avons
davantage sincérité il oublie de dire
dans sa démonstration que nous avons
auprès la dette de la sncf
et ce n'était pas une petite affaire de
mettre fin à leur statut du cheminot sûr
mais également de sa série zelda qu'en
sait tous que c'est elle qui dicte
personne ne voulait la voir
et c'était vous le savez lire plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros nous
l'avons intégrée et on a réussi à
stabiliser et à baisser la dette alors
même monsieur le rapporteur général
nous avons remplacé dizaine de milliards
d'euros dans le stock de votre
comparaison avec d'autres pays sur le
papier peut faire florès mais elle ne
résiste pas hérité de la crise et donc
ne pas aider les territoires n'ont pas
été simples entreprises publiques et
l'agent de venir on avait su que j'en
reprends la tête mais on sait tous qu'un
autre gouvernement aurait dû faire la
vérité des chiffres et c'est vous qui
l'avez c est le poids qu'on peut être
fier de cette sincérité sur la question
de la desserte entre l'allemagne et la
france
le cas d'accord il faudra probablement
faire la comparaison entre l'italie et
la france
bon évidemment la même c'est mieux c'est
mieux parce que les finances publiques
étaient méconnus je rappelle comment la
crise financière le rapporteur général
nous fêtons la france au nom de ma la
crise financière c'est à dire au moment
où par exemple résidents hollande a
rendu de son mandat aux français les
allemands et est retombé à 65% après
avoir touché 90 et non mais restait 90
alors c'est sûr que quand vous arrivez
avec une tête à 65 et pas de déficit
budgétaire
enfin avant appliqué à 98 avec un
déficit budgétaire c'est évident que
vous êtes un peu moins bien armés
emprunter sur les marchés financiers
pourraient se comparer avec ne soit pas
plus qu il considérait que la france a
fait mieux quand même bon je crois que
la france et l'a montré qu'elle était
capable d'emprunter boucou très
rapidement était pas être attaqué sur
les marchés financiers et j'entends
beaucoup de sceptiques c'est quand même
grâce à l'euro que notre mode et n'a pas
été attaqué aussi si nous avions eu une
modèle national avec le niveau de
finances publiques que nous avions
peut-être mais ont été attaqués au moins
laurent instabilité a sauvé les
quotidiens princesse quand même
contribué semble passionner les
économies européennes
il suffit dans la déclaration
aujourd'hui des hauts responsables du
budget britannique pour s'apercevoir
qu'on était quand c'est pas toujours si
ça de vivre tout seul
vous évoquez les lions de dépenses sur
la voie de règlement alors les 150
millions sur le pôle intérieur vous avez
raison
et pourquoi est-ce que 50 millions
d'euros de plus d'abord parce que les
victimes en le protocole aux gendarmes
policiers signe en décembre 2018 qui est
appliqué en 2019 ou des revalorisations
salariales
ça a été aussi le cas des stocks
d'heures supplémentaires que nous avons
payé pas tout mais il mon parti mais
j'avais vu qu'un accord notamment l
année dernière entre les intérieurs une
équipe nautique et les syndicats de
policiers vont payer ses stocks heures
supplémentaires qu'ils n'étaient pas
plus très longtemps pour les policiers
et puis les mouvements sociaux qui ne
sont pas échappés
il ya eu un geste très mouvementée il a
fallu mettre doctorat page d'effectifs
et davantage de mobilisation
et tout ça ça près 150 millions d'euros
de plus j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
plusieurs fois discuté avec les
intérieurs il est tout à fait conscient
des choses étaient beaucoup de réformes
du ministre à l'intérieur sur ce point
on va essayer de toucher au maximum des
inscriptions budgétaires pour vous avez
mis en place et a plus d'argent
même si les ans comprend tout à fait
pourquoi aimez ça dépend public il ya un
parti clairement participé
on a 150 millions d'euros 2,2 pouces sur
en france très haut débit le retard
était sur l'épreuve des projets des
contraintes opérationnelles et pas
seulement d'argent et sur des chantiers
nouveau développement de réseaux vous
savez pas ce que vous avez présidé un
département qui a aussi deux opérateurs
des collectivités locales qui nous
aident sans doute que je viens dans mon
lit et monomères pourrait davantage
d'expliciter ses retards mais ce n'est
pas une question d'argent qui a manqué
ou de détail qui a traîné ses des
contraintes opérationnelles nous a pas
posé la question sur de justice et je
croyais labour puisque la justice
la formation m6 vous allez voter n'a pas
atteint le niveau de dépenses c'est par
des économies qu'elle aurait vis à des
cotes fixes ses parements de
construction de prisons parce que les
collectivités locales et on peut les
comprendre à votre société
mais la libérer des terrains pour faire
ses prisons mais par exemple devront
empocher les ventes de tv prévu dans la
victoire de 8 6 alors que nous n'avons
pas le nombre de prisons prévues pour ce
n'est pas le sens des politiques qui à
rosny et la session budgétaire la loi de
formation voilà votre président merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre a alors
mes chers collègues vous êtes nombreux à
vous inscrire au moment où je vous parle
j'ai déjà une liste de onze
questionneurs si je puis dire et donc
sans plus tarder nous nous tournons vers
vincent delahaye le premier ces
questions vincent delahaye kouilou que
la leçon oui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
bonjour à tous
c'est vrai qu'on peut mettre au crédit
du gouvernement à la fois sa sincérité
et la bonne tenue des recettes
en revanche moi je suis plus critique
sur la partie dépense est bon bénéficie
effectivement de taux très bas ce qui
fait qu'on fait les intérêts de la dette
mais si cette dette ne servait qu'à
financer des investissements je trouvais
sera de près sain et très profitable
malheureusement la grande majorité de
notre dette paye du fonctionnement donc
on paye du fonctionnement d'aujourd'hui
en tirant des tracts sur les générations
futures je passe après responsable mais
c'est pas sûr qu'il reste on vit comme
ça ma question sur la la loi de
règlement c'était le montant des
dépenses d'investissement dans cette loi
de règlement
à combien sommes-nous effectivement sur
un budget de 400 milliards
combien de dépenses d'investissement
somme de questions qui effectivement des
bords de la loi de règlement mais on
n'avait pas répondu sur la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
vous m'entendez bien vous n'avez pas
répondu parce que si on a des perrés
faire effectivement à la fois d'urgence
et de résilience
mais quand il va falloir aborder
le projet un projet de financement de
relance je pense qu'il serait
souhaitable avant d'avoir une
programmation des finances publiques
pour voir au delà de l'exercice 2020
comment on rétablit progressivement même
pas l'équipe
mais comment on revient à une situation
plus habituel je dirais de nos finances
publiques
et je crois qu'avec une loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
doit nous permettre
et moi je pense qu'il serait souhaitable
avant ou en même temps que le plan de
relance
ça c'était ma deuxième question la
troisième c'est sur les sur les niches
fiscales
olivier dussopt pts a annoncé de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée
nationale que vous alliez revoir un
certain nombre de niches fiscales par
rapport à leur couleur verte ou pas en
fait la partie environnementale de ces
niches
moi je souhaiterais qu'on aille plus
loin est ce que vous pensez qu'un mâle
et un peu plus loin
alors je sais que le parlement vous
n'êtes pas toujours ni sénat d'ailleurs
dans ce sens là mais moi je suis
partisan de de supprimer pas mal de
niche qu'ils sont jugées inefficaces
est-ce que vous irez dans ce sens là
quant à monsieur le président merci
vincent ils ont que l'un puis sylvie
vermeillet ils vont oui merci monsieur
le président à man le jour chaque
collègue monsieur le ministre
merci d'avoir développé largement la loi
de règlement comme le rapporteur général
monsieur le président hu a eu l'élégance
de loups les six autres questions mais
je les remercie alors j'ai quelques
questions d'abord monsieur le ministre
l'hypothèse d'une récession limitée à 8%
en moyenne annuelle en 2020 l'hypothèse
sur laquelle est fondée la loi de
finances rectificative du 25 avril
dernier suppose
nous le savons un rebond de la
consommation notamment portée par une
forte des d épargne à sion peut
s'exprimer ainsi des ménages français on
sait que nos concitoyens l'ont fortement
épargné depuis le début du confinement
avez-vous pensé à des leviers pour
inciter les français à désépargner pour
consommer davantage dans les prochains
mois si ma première question
ensuite les finances locales vont être
fortement affectés par la crise
sanitaire les maires sont inquiets et
les collectivités locales en général
avec une baisse des recettes fiscales ou
conjuguée à une amende
sur des passes est ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas envisager que les dépenses liées à
la crise puisse d'être passé puis c'est
peut-être passé à l'investissement et ce
pour ne pas grever les dépenses de
fonctionnement sinon où aller la piste
qui consisterait à isoler pour chaque
collectivité la dépense dans un budget
annexe dix spéciales cos vide en fait
dernière question de la réforme de la
taxe d'habitation
si j'ai bien compris monsieur le
ministre va se poursuivre et ce malgré
l'impact d'un risque sanitaire sur les
finances publiques le gouvernement l'a
confirmé allant jusqu'à évoquer un
possible effet d'aubaine que répondez
vous au fait que la substitution de la
fpp par une part de tva dans un contexte
de forte épargne et de chute de la
consommation pourrait être très
impactante pour les finances du
département
voilà monsieur le ministre mes trois
questions je vous remercie
des réponses ce que vous voudrez bien y
apporter merci à l'enclin sylvie
vermeillet puis arnaud bazin bonjour
monsieur le président chers collègues
bonjour monsieur le ministre
concernant l'exécution budgétaire 2019
et plus précisément le casse pension
dont je suis rapporteur spécial je note
que le niveau de la retraite unitaire
moyenne des fonctionnaires baisse depuis
2010 et tout particulièrement pour les
catégories b et c est à la fois du fait
du durcissement des conditions de durée
d'assurance et d'âge bien sûr j'aimerais
savoir si je pouvais tenir
l'actualisation de ses deux les corps
2019 alors pas forcément aujourd'hui
j'aimerais en être destinataire et puis
dans la perspective de la future réforme
des retraites à moins qu'il ne soit
définitivement enterré pensez vous que
la situation des actifs de la fonction
publique alors principalement les
policiers les militaires et gérard
j'irais volontiers aux personnels
hospitaliers
pensez vous que la situation de ces
actifs puissent être favorablement
révisé ensuite j'ai la demande à vous
transmettre de notre collecte polynésie
nuit on l'aurait qui à cette heure ne
peut pas se joindre à nous au sujet de
la caisse de prévoyance sociale de la
polynésie française qui est équivalente
au champ d'action de la cnam de la cnam
de la caf et de l'urssaf ont métropole
et nouilles on nous dit que la crise
économique et les mesures de report de
paiement des cotisations ont un effet
immédiat sur la trésorerie de cette
caisse de sorte que si aucune nouvelle
source de liquidités nettes identifier
d'ici juillet prochain les prestations
sociales de polynésie ne pourront plus
être honorées cela concerne les pensions
de retraite les remboursements
d'assurance maladie les dotations de
fonctionnement des hôpitaux les
allocations familiales etc
en ce sens le président de la polynésie
française vous a adressé une demande
d'emprunt à l'instar des dispositions
prises pour la nouvelle calédonie donc
notre collègue guyot lauret souhaiterais
savoir monsieur le ministre si vous
allez répondre favorablement à cette
demande et si les dispositions peuvent
être opérationnel d'ici juillet je vous
remercie
merci c'est lui arnaud bazin
puis roger karoutchi arnaud bazin merci
monsieur le président je suis le
ministre mes chers collègues me schmitt
vous avez évoqué à plusieurs reprises et
l'effort de sensibilisation des comptes
qui a été entrepris sur votre autorité
mais en ce qui concerne la prime
d'activité l'exécution budgétaire 2019
est encore en dépassement puisque cette
exécution s'élève à plus de 9 milliards
et demi soit un dépassement de près de
800 millions d'euros par rapport à la
prévision
alors certes il y avait un contexte
d'urgence qui a présidé à la réforme du
dispositif
mais comment expliquez-vous quand même
sept sous budgétisation récurrentes et
quelles sont les actions entreprises par
votre ministère pour permettre une
budgétisation plus sincères du
dispositif et puisqu'on et a invité par
le président et rapporteur général a
évoqué l' exécution 2020 toujours sur la
prime d'activité vous avez inscrit 9 9
milliards d'euros est ce que vous pensez
à ce stade que cette prévision tiendra
ou 1
déplacement et ils à prévoir de même il
a été instauré donc un dispositif des de
nos compatriotes les plus en difficulté
avec une prime exceptionnelle de 150
euros augmentée de 100 euros par enfant
du ménage c est mon telle vocation à
être financés sur l' enveloppe de 880
millions identifiés lors du plfr de au
sein de la mission solidarité
si oui il semblerait que cette enveloppe
ne devra être complétée compte tenu des
besoins pour couvrir lettre de
solidarité et l'aide aux étudiants
précaires ou comment assurer
l'intégralité du financement qui
risquent de monter à pratiquement 1
milliard d'euros des mouvements
budgétaires sont ils prévus pour couvrir
ce besoin et pensez vous par ailleurs
que les caf qui sont déjà fort
sollicités trouverons les moyens
d'assurer cette prestation dans des
conditions de délai raisonnable enfin
sur l'aide alimentaire qui est un sujet
important également dans notre rapport
spécial avec éric bocquet les dépenses
financées par la mission solidarité
insertion égalité des chances sont
élevées à 58 millions d'euros soit un
dépassement de plus de 7 millions
d'euros par rapport aux crédits inscrits
au défi cet écart est préoccupant parce
que il est certainement dû à
l'augmentation des dépenses déclarées
inéligibles les quartiers les demandes
de remboursement par l'union européenne
dans le cadre du fait là c'est un point
vraiment soulevé à plusieurs reprises
dans nos rapports de contrôle
monsieur le ministre est ce que la
france va pouvoir récupérer la totalité
de ses fonds européens le budget
national devra t-il financer ce manque à
gagner
enfin sur les prévisions concernant 2020
chacun sait que nombre de nos
compatriotes sont sont appelés
malheureusement être de plus en plus en
difficulté
les associations d'aidé alimentaire sont
extrêmement sollicité l'aide qu'ils
bénéficiaient avant la crise d'un 5 5
millions de personnes concernées près de
8 millions d'après votre collègue
christian gross dans une interview
récemment donné donc le gouvernement a
annoncé une enveloppe de 39 millions
d'euros à des associations
cette aide est elle parvenue aux
associations ou en t pris ses crédits
dans
d'état et autres aides financières
seront à débloquer sur le plan national
voire européen
merci merci arnaud bazin roger karoutchi
auquel succèdera charles guené roger
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général et cher collègue
monsieur le ministre
beaucoup de plaisir de vous retrouver en
forme moi j'aurai deux observations
question si je puis dire
première observation question est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment sur le budget
2010 9 que les mesures prises d'urgence
dite gilet jaune en décembre 2018 ont
réellement atteint leurs doutes leurs
objectifs il ya eu par la suite beaucoup
de critiques sur la précipitation sur un
certain nombre de mesures qui finalement
été assez coûteuse
il n'avait peut-être pas obtenu les
résultats escomptés
est-ce que là dessus vous avez le
sentiment que la dizaine de milliards
concernés à relativement atteint son but
deuxième observation de questions
rapidement en tant que rapporteur sur
l'audiovisuel je ne vous cache pas que
je regarde désespérément la capacité de
ce secteur à faire quelques économies
je reste sur le désespérément et comme
vous aviez imaginé envisagé soit la
disparition au profit d'autres choses de
la redevance audiovisuelle soit son
réajustement avec la disparition de la
taxe d'habitation est ce que sur ce plan
là votre réflexion a avancé merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre a même si
cher roger charles guené puis thierry
carcenac charles guené oui merci
monsieur le président bonjour à tous
monsieur le président c'est le
rapporteur général monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
peut-être tout d'abord une question donc
je suis naturellement portée plus vers
les collectivités locales pour
l'exécution de crédit 2019
vous savez qu'à la la mission aux deux
relations collectivités locales on a
toujours un décalage entre les
autorisations
l'engagement et les crédits de paiement
au niveau des subventions
d'investissement et ça permet assez
difficilement de suivre l'investissement
local et plus particulièrement cette
année d'autant plus que les indicateurs
de performance sont relativement plus
adaptée adapté puisque seule la detr
fait l'objet d'un suivi
ne croyez vous pas que ce serait
l'occasion ne serait ce qu'au moins pour
le plf on puisse mettre un peu d'ordre
dans tout ça on puisse suivre beaucoup
plus facilement les choses
je demanderai donc bien sûr sur
l'exécution 2020 qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous avez bu
beaucoup d'avant ce qu'ont bien que deux
collectivités on demandait d avance sur
lui tva et combien de de demande pour
quel montant
et d'une manière plus générale est ce
que pour le fctva
vous réfléchissez dans le cadre de la
relance à le rendre plus contemporain
est ce que ça vous paraît comme cela a
été fait à une époque qu'est ce que ça
vous paraît farfelue ou est-ce que c'est
dans vous dans votre esprit également
est ce que vous avez à nous savons que
nous avons envoyé à vos préfet au préfet
donc des directives pour propager plus
rapidement la detr l'a décidé
mais est-ce que vous avez un état de
l'engagement actuel
et puis si vous me permettez un peu de
prospective dans le le cadre où nous
nous trouvons au niveau des réformes et
tout ça
ne pensez vous pas qu on aurait
peut-être intérêt au niveau des indices
synthétiques qui qui vont être
bouleversées il fait de la réforme de la
th à trouver un dispositif de
neutralisation de même qu en ce qui
concerne l'idée de revenir sur les
impôts économique est ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'on aurait intérêt à
laisser tout ça au calme en attendant
que
la crise se passe de façon à ce que les
collectivités locales ne soient pas
perturbés dans la vision de la ressource
tout ça merci parfait merci farl thierry
carcenac et ensuite christine lagarde
thierry carcenac merci monsieur le
président bonjour chers collègues
monsieur le ministre je ne doutais pas
en vous entendant présenté la loi de
règlement que vous seriez content du
travail que vous avez effectué ses
doutes est normal pour un ministre
néanmoins ce ce que l'on peut constater
également c'est que nous avons eu à
faire des mesures d'urgence la suite de
la crise des gilets jaunes et que nous
allons arriver à une situation qui est
bien plus préoccupante dans la foulée
avec ce que nous vivons après la crise
sanitaire actuelle date les économique
qui vient et la crise sociale sûrement
qui risquent de ce pacte est derrière
cela
vous avez bien évidemment indiqué que
vous étiez fonds à monsieur la non
création bien qu'au niveau j'ai lu
l'autre jour que monsieur s'oublier
conseiller de monsieur sarkozy il disait
être il faudrait qu'en matière de
solidarité
nous pensions à quelques recettes
nouvelles alors c'est pas pour tout de
suite puisque nous sommes dans le cadre
de l'exécution et je me fais des sites
comme vous que vous ayez pu nous
permettre d'avoir ces éléments
relativement tôt mais qui nous
permettront d'examiner la loi de
finances 2021 avec des éléments
peut-être différent et notamment en
matière de ressources mais question
concerne bien évidemment lu le rapport
que avec mon collègue jeunes nous
portons et notamment celui qui concerne
l'immobilier de l'état et dans le cadre
de l'immobilier de l'état
nous avons constaté notamment sur le
programme 348 cité administrative qui
dial
en démarrage relativement lent et dans
ce cadre là
comment envisagez-vous de pouvoir dans
le 15e relance se faire en sorte que
bien on puisse aller plus rapidement
notamment dans le cadre de la transition
environnementale parce que ça nous
permettra de faire un par ailleurs des
économies
c'était un premier point le second j'ai
noté que vous avez évoqué la francisque
had et notamment vous avez mis un être
du datamining si j'ai bien compris en
2019 on a eu des difficultés de
recrutement de personnel la matière
informatique sur le data mining pour
vivre pourriez vous nous en dire un peu
plus de ce côté enfin je m'étonne c'est
page méthodes non mais je constate que
nous affectons de plus en plus de tva la
sécurité sociale est on
cela risque de poser quand même pas mal
de problèmes un jour là nous sommes à
près de 35 milliards de cette année
comment voyez-vous l'avenir sans coller
une vision parfois globale de ce qui
passe du budget de l'état au budget de
la sécurité sociale
je vous remercie merci thierry christine
lagarde
oui la flandre mais seuls présidents
donc monsieur me disais comment j'ai
trois questions la première audience et
a dit à l'instant thierry carcenac avec
qui je siège le conseil de l'immobilier
de l'état et donc je voudrais revenir
sur le compte de commerce des opérations
du domaine qui présentait un solde très
élevé donc vous avez répondu pour partie
à allah de falla remarques de la cour
des comptes qui vous demandait de faire
un report partiel puisque sur les 124
millions vous avez annuler nous reporter
environ 51 millions
mais ce qui porte quand même le crédit
du solde à 73 millions au début de
l'année 2020 et en 2018 vous aviez déjà
fait ce type de manoeuvre vous aviez en
était parti de 68 millions donc c'est un
conte de commerce dont les recettes
croit ce très vite et qui portent des
dépenses plutôt faible 50 millions en
2019 et majoritairement pour justement
la gestion des sinistres
active et donc dans l'exposé des motifs
de la loi de règlement vous dites que
vous souhaitez conserver un montant de
prudentielles de trésorerie pour des
dépenses exceptionnelles
donc est-ce que vous avez une idée de ce
que pourrait être ses dépenses ma
deuxième question est relative au fonds
pour la transformation de l'action
publique
donc je me souviens que lors de vos
premières auditions en 2017 vous aviez
notamment évoqué ce fonds comme un des
acteurs de l'action publique 2022
et on remarque en fait les règles du jeu
ou un petit peu et et évoluer puisque
pour les premiers appels d'offres
il y avait une cible de rendement qui
devait être d'un euro économies pour un
euro investi dès 3 ans et pour le
quatrième appel d'offres les règles sont
a soutenu puisque on n'a plus forcément
besoin d'atteindre cette cible pour être
retenu donc pourquoi avez-vous à
soutenir les critères d'éligibilité et
enfin ma dernière question du coût
concernera 2020 mais donc dans sa note
d'exécution budgétaire la cour des
comptes demande la suppression du compte
d'affectation spéciale service ans
nationaux de transport conventionnelle
voyageurs donc allez vous répondre à
cette demande pour le prochain ps merci
christine lagarde quelques l'ange de
reinach là après claude philippe dallier
oui bonjour monsieur le président mes
chats collègues bonjour monsieur le
ministre
comme thierry carcenac j'ai eu plaisir à
écouter votre introduction et je dois
dire que que ce soit en présentiel aussi
dingue que ce soit en visioconférence la
tonalité rse là même une certaine
satisfaction du travail accompli je vous
en félicite
mais cela étant dit quelquefois
historique quand même qu'il faut
toujours remettre en particulier vous
avez juste oublié lorsque vous êtes
arrivé effectivement aux affaires en
la croissance était vous être une
croissance à 2 3% et c'était la première
fois depuis bien longtemps qu'elle
dépasser un niveau moyen qu a plutôt été
sur les cinq derniers
les précédentes cinq années précédentes
du taux de 1% alors évidemment ça aide
comment dire à résoudre un certain
nombre un certain nombre de points et je
voudrais vous rappeler celui que vous
avez cités avait lui trouver une
situation à 0 2% de croissance c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose et c'était vos
amis de l'époque qui l'avait laissé
coûteuses et peu point un peu général et
puis je me finit là et j'en reste là le
gouvernement sur l'époque sarkozy trois
points de moins et une récupération de
propos de déficit public sous les
poteaux landes un peu plus de deux
points
pour l'instant nous concernant c'est à
peine 1 % de déficit public qui a été
récupérée maintenant on en parle plus
puisque c'est plus le sujet du moment
enfin j'ai été étonné dans votre
introduction de votre propos une figure
ont finalement refusé l'impôt et si j'ai
bien compris ce propos général c'est un
propos qui finalement se tourner vers
votre propre majorité
parce que c'est dans votre propre
majorité aujourd'hui qu'il y à une
ébullition autour des sujets sur l'impôt
faut-il augmenter une tranche
supplémentaire
faut-il remettre en place l'impôt sur la
fortune c'est des sujets que nous ayons
bien concerné socialiste n'a
effectivement vous répondiez plutôt à
votre propre majorité
alors pour en venir maintenant à la
discussion des crédits début 19 d'abord
un point d'information sur 2019 ou un
point d'interrogation en tout cas c'est
concernant le la mission qui est la
nôtre avec charles guené sur les
relations avaient des collectivités
territoriales on a un peu de mal avec le
bleu budgétaire parce qu'effectivement
cette mission recouvre une diversité de
dotations sur laquelle finalement un
seul indicateur est à peu près
pertinence et celui sur la 2 e tr il
fait l'objet d'un suivi à peu près
précis sur l'ensemble du reste des
indicateurs de performance de la mission
sont extrêmement généraux et évasif est
ce que on pourrait faire mieux dans les
années qui viennent cela ma première
question deuxième question qui concerne
le ctv à 2020
là j'ai bien sûr un peu la période
qu'une condition on savoir si vous
finalement vous avez eu à ce jour
beaucoup de demandes d'acomptes sur ctv
à deux niveaux est-ce que vous avez une
idée du montant déjà engagées au titre
d' avance enfin je voudrais revenir sur
le propos de charles guené sur les deux
tiers des cils et c'est quand vous
faisant une dernière question il s'agit
de savoir les projets sont engagés
évidemment de longue date sur des
montants fixés au moment du dépôt du
dossier de l'acceptation du dossier
et bien entendu avec la crise que nous
connaissons est levé sur charges
financières qui vont être qu'ils vont
mettre le fait des entreprises qui
répondent aux projets des collectivités
locales nous allons avoir des surcoûts
et donc la nécessité sans doute pour les
collectivités locales de payer un peu
plus cher leur prestation est-ce que
vous avez imaginé donner un peu de
liberté au préfet dans le cadre de
l'enveloppé qu'elle est un jeu parce
qu'il ya des projets qui seront
forcément arrêté ou freiner dans le
cadre de l' enveloppe est ce qu'il y
aura des possibilités tout oppressé
finalement d'adapter d'adapter
rapidement de manière à en coupe les
surcoûts des entreprises pour les
projets déjà affecté au poids dans le
cadre d'une enveloppe globale inchangée
est ce que cette instruction pourrait
être donnée au préfet je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
merci enchères claude raynal nous
entendons maintenant philippe dallier
puis jean françois husson philippe
dallier halo m'entendez oui oui papa
merci monsieur lune et je suis désolé
j'ai pas pu vous entendre suite au
changement d'horaire donc je ne sais pas
si vous avez abordé le sujet mais nous
parler et qui m'ont des crédits du
logement en particulier
et de la dette de l'état vis-à-vis du
chenal dans le report de la réforme des
apl t3 les techniques l'an dernier vous
a amené à les faire ouvrir 627 millions
d'euros de crédits supplémentaires et
pour autant la dette de l'état vis-à-vis
du chenal s'est accru de 173 millions
l'année dernière qui viennent s'ajouter
à la dette cumulée les années
précédentes et j'ai en tête quand je
n'ai pas le chiffre exact doit être à
peu près aux alentours de 700 millions
en cumulé en 2001 la réforme des appels
est reporté sine et y ai cru comprendre
qu'elle ne serait pas mise en place eu
égard à la situation que nous
connaissons
or dans les deux premiers tlf faire vous
n'avez pas corrigé le tir en matière
d'inscription budgétaires je sais pas si
vous le ferez dans le plfr tran mais si
vous ne le faisais pas monsieur le
ministre on pourrait arriver à une dette
qui frôle les 2 milliards d'euros dette
existante et puis à 1 milliard et
peut-être plus pour l'année 2020
d'autant ta situation économique et
sociale se dégrade et qu'effectivement
le nombre d'allocataires pourrait
augmenter de manière relativement
important donc ça c'est ma première
question et j'ai besoin d'une précision
par ailleurs parce que dans le compte
général de l'état
il est fait état d'une autre dette qui
est relative aux frais de gestion d
appeler et les chiffres qui nous sont
données sont une dette de 137 millions
en 2010 est de 229 millions en 2018 et
de 664 millions en 2019
et là on parle bien des frais de gestion
et pas des prestations donc est ce que
ces dettes prestation d'un côté frais de
gestion ce cumul ou sais c'est ça ma
question parce que je crains
effectivement de fin de l'hiver on
approche les 2 milliards est-ce que la
dette sur les frais de gestion est
acculé également douala métier sur le
chômage
merci philippe sont des techniques
habituelles merci de son en soit il
s'enfuit jean bizet jean-françois oui
monsieur le président de ce ministère
collègues
bonjour moi je vais m'en tenir à la loi
de règlement
2019 sur un sujet vous savez monsieur le
ministre qui m'est chère qui est le
sujet de l'écologie
il ya trois questions en 2019 en fait
l'exercice aura été marqué par
l'intégration du dispositif de la prime
à la conversion dans un programme de 174
ce qui est d'un inconvénient ne sont
utiles puisque ça n'est plus financée
par les recettes du malus auto c'est une
prime qui ad'ailleurs préalablement été
le sensiblement transformé pour ne pas
dire raboté en juillet 2019 assez
brutalement dans une logique purement
comptable et je m'inscris d'ailleurs
dans les propos de vincent delahaye
d'utiliser il faudrait supprimer les
niches inefficaces trt vous vous avez
raboter unis ce que j'appelle efficace
mais vous allez encore nous faire le
numéro sur les lisieux où le fait
souvent
première question quel bilan tirez-vous
de cette opération qui finalement a
consisté à et pire les critères
d'accession à la prime parce qu'elle
fonctionnait très bien
et d'une certaine manière coûter trop
cher à l'état
je dois dire que quand on voit ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui les enjeux écologiques
et les moyens pour assurer la transition
de nombreux domaines me semble devoir
continuer à être une priorité
priorité que manifestement vous avez un
peu ou même assez sensiblement à côté en
2019 par ailleurs la france a fait
l'objet par la cour de justice de
l'union européenne d'une part appel est
astreinte
parce qu'elles ne respectaient pas à
certains nombre de dents en matière de
pollution atmosphérique
il ya des possibilités financières qui
sont en perspective d'un sous forme
d'astreinte
où en est-on où en est la france
aujourd'hui à ce sujet à combien les
pénalités sont elles évaluées et
sont-elles provisionné au bon niveau
enfin en lien avec cette deuxième
question l'accident lubrizol en 2019
fait encore parler de lui avec la crise
pandémique
on va dire quand en france la culture du
risque n'est peut-être pas affrètement
anticiper qu'elle soit sanitaires mais
euh ça dépasse la france ou
d'industriels d'ailleurs dans le plf
2020 dans le programme de prévention des
risques naturels technologiques ou
nucléaires
je dirais aucune leçon ne semble avoir
été tirée à ce moment là puisque aucun
crédit supplémentaire s'il est si mes
souvenirs sont bons nos mentalités que
les crédits ont même baissé
comment un seul stade justifiez-vous
cette position et comment dans la
perspective du projet de loi de finances
2010 21 entendez vous remédier à cette
situation comme dieu créa
merci merci à jean françois husson
jambes beasley depuis le dernier inscrit
en tout cas un instant jean marc gabouty
jean bizet d'abord merci monsieur le
président vous m'entendez on aimerait
bien mais merci monsieur le président
bonjour mes chers collègues bonjour
monsieur le ministre
d'abord mes chemises permettez moi de
m'excuser parce que je n'ai pas entendu
votre prestation tout à l'heure j'étais
retenu par l'audition de l'ambassadeur
d'allemagne en poste à paris monsieur
meyer landrut précisément sur une
question qui avait trait à l'euro moi je
voudrais vous livrer ma grande
inquiétude sur l'avenir précisément de
l'euro au regard de peu
deux paramètres importants d'abord
l'avis de la cour de justice de la cour
de cartouches récemment et surtout sur
la divergence qui va croissante entre la
france et l'allemagne déficit annuel
après déficit annuel un montant je
dirais de dettes que vous savez et nous
traînons le péché originel de la
construction de la monnaie unique avec
deux visions que je qualifierais
d'antagonistes un petit peu celle du
président collet mitterrand qui avait
décidé de prendre une décision politique
avant je dirais de prendre en compte un
minimum de de convergence qui était la
position à l'époque de jacques delors
donc aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus en
convergence sur beaucoup de points et
donc ma question est très simple
quelles sont monsieur le ministre les
convergences que vous imagineriez mettre
désormais rapidement en oeuvre pour
éviter une fracture franco allemande que
je sens de plus en plus irrémédiable et
une rélégation de la france dans les
pays de l'europe du sud avec pourquoi
pas l'émergence d'un euro à double
vitesse un euro des pays d'europe du
nord et un euro des pays d'europe du sud
merci de votre réponse merci chers j'en
ai donc jean marc gabouty jean-marc es
tu là oui allô il marque le temps
pendant oui merci
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre bonjour s'appelait simplement
revenir sur quelque chose que vous avez
évoqué monsieur ministre était là la
fiscalité affecté que je suis un peu au
niveau de la commission et en étant
rapporteur qu'on d'affectation spéciale
des amendes
amendes de police et des amendes de
radars il me semble que cette fiscalité
affectés parfois qu'une illusion de
traçabilité et lorsque la source fiscale
se tarit elle met en difficulté
l'émission qui en sont bénéficiaires
je ne prendrai que l'exemple de la fif
qui est financé par la tei cpe part
effectivement le compte d'affectation
spécial à man la menthe d'orateur et une
redevance sur les sociétés des recettes
des sociétés d'autoroutes
vous imaginez ce que ça peut donner sur
l'année 2020 la question qui est plus
général est ce que vous seriez favorable
à présenter j'ai tiré un projet de
réforme en vue de la simplification et
delà de la réduction de l'ensemble du
dispositif de fiscalité affectés merci
jean marc alors monsieur le ministre
nous en allons terminer avec les
questions vous voyez mais vous en avez
l'habitude que la liste est assez longue
les sujets diversifiés mais j'ai observé
avec attention que vous aviez pris des
notes selon de l'expression de mes
collègues et donc je ne doute pas que
vous en avez l'habitude vous allez
pouvoir répondre à chacun et toutes ces
thématiques
nous vous écoutons avec intérêt merci
monsieur le président peut-être
commençant par les questions assure
monsieur a posé la question dans son
montant des investissements
je reviens pas sur la on était doté de
cette question n'est pas nouveau si je
prends l'exemple du montant de l'année
2009 4 milliard question
d'investissement sont plus 600 millions
d'euros ont été mis dans le budget des
dépenses de fonctionnement c'est une
question qui ne va pas poser mais je lui
réponds bien volontiers
cinquante trois de cinq c'est le montant
en milliards et c'était 54,1 en 2018
constatera donc à hull 600 millions
d'euros
on est moins de 600 millions d'euros de
fonctionnement et lycées
sont pas comme nous disiez que deux
correspondants les collectivités locales
notamment rationné finances publiques je
n'ai pas répondu parce que chacun voit
d'abord ici que ce n'est pas sur des
comptes publics sur nous de faire ses
annonces à monsieur est honnête mais
finances le rapporteur général parce que
vos ministres lui à l'heure pas écrit en
automne dernier pour dire que dans
l'année 2020 à l'époque n'étant pas le
coc vide il v2 grâce à des tuiles qui
veulent pousser à ne pas présenter les
choses au parlement en septembre octobre
2002 bof c'est el assad du brésil à
cette étude du débat ce que les autres
entre temps les habitudes se sont plutôt
accéléré et a grandi à vide
donc je ne peux pas répondre à la
question je vous souhaite une à titre
personnel mais je vois bien en quoi
c'est prématuré de l'évoquer que les
critères et les difficultés chaume
quasiment au jour le jour et à coût de
milliards à coup de dizaines de
milliards en dépenses
cependant je voudrais rassurer le
parlement il est bien prévu à
dépasserait dans les relations explique
sur lequel le gouvernement bien
évidemment une prospective
il était prévu fin juin elle ne sera pas
reportée et donc on aura sans doute
l'occasion à ce moment là on importe
c'est de faire une fois très
certainement évoqués par mois sur le
premier ministre
la loi des finances de plantation des
finances publiques qui est effectivement
nécessaire mais dans les chiffres que de
pauvreté aujourd'hui serait tout relatif
jeu qu'elle comprendra et mérite est
d'être largement modifié si nous avions
trois temps sur les niches fiscales
comme la question sur les dépenses verte
qu'évoquer du soft je me suis engagé
devant le parlement je vous écris en lui
donnant une copie du rapport que j'ai
commandé à l'inspection générale des
finances ont semé la bougie et le vert
pour que le parlement puisse
effectivement regarder ce qui relève des
dépenses et des recettes non pas
simplement des potable c'est évidemment
important mais de l'efficacité de la
politique publique en termes de gammes
montré le rapport de l'inspection des
finances à lui raté tous ses départs de
très nombreux objets à des
parlementaires des calculs et nous
sommes les seuls à lormont en place ce
budget s'effectueront qu'à faire comme
cela m s'est engagé quand des militaires
depuis sur le général document que nous
ferons c'est que d'abord un et d'aider
très compliqué a priori avoir une
réponse claire sur qu'est-ce qu'une
dépense comme nantes
qu'est ce que pense pas qu 90 jeunes
explique si vous construisez un km de
chemins de fer ou plus considérer que
c'est une dépense qui est verte puisque
évidemment à mimi le meaux de gaz à
effet de serre mais si notre critère
c'est la biodiversité construire la
cabane de chemin de fer nouveau c'est
pas bon signe pour la biodiversité
le nucléaire est un exemple chacun
construit sera de sa patine dépend
certes beaucoup moins de co2 ne résidant
pas en revanche et en public évêché
c'est pas très bon pour l'environnement
donc c'est un débat qui est pas très
sain même s'il est très intéressant et
nous voulons leur a appelé quelques on
s'est aperçu de particulier c'est que
les niches fiscales en temps la dépense
fiscale était particulièrement brune
s'était pas à la magie c'est bien
évidemment vont se poser le fait qu'elle
n'était pas verte et notamment sa
déclaration ou de parlementaire et
politique les dépenses fiscales qui
relève de logements de
l'artificialisation des sols la façon
dont je suis malade extrêmes ils ne
connaissent aucun dispositif sur lequel
nous avons souvent des débats
est-ce qu'ils n est pas la gauche de son
logement ils peuvent s'attendre guilhem
et d'éléphants dans le territoire ils
connaissent des difficultés pour
construire des logements voire des
contres il y perd eh bien nous voyons de
75 % de dépenses fiscales sont des
dépenses négatif pour l'environnement
mais le choix est un choix politique
éminemment parce que le souhaiterait
si nous partons du principe que les
bouchons des dépenses fiscales mais les
bords tout pour que à l'aune de
l'environnement c'est sans doute un
choix de civilisation très important il
faut savoir que sa part d'aller des
défauts et les défauts notamment sur la
construction le développement et vous
savez une personne par les expériences
que moi otx toujours choisir entre deux
difficultés
mais vous aurez ces documents et vous
avez déjà votre apport la structure
générale
si vous n'avez pas reçu cela
m'étonnerait je peux leur envoyer déjà
un certain nombre d'éléments sur le
budget étudiant de 18 ans ministère dont
des ministères qui auront le plus de
dépenses sociales
le sénateur prg a évoqué plusieurs
questions avant le rebond de sensations
suite n 2 sur et pardon c'est ayant une
question très intéressante de voir que
les français alors pas dans leur
totalité
il est évident des différences entre
pensée des gens qui connaissent des
difficultés sociales extrêmement fortes
dans le moment du livre mais que
beaucoup de français ont été par nous
mêmes en plus s'épargner côté l'étude
j'ai compris que le mono 60 milliards
d'euros avait été évoqué on va donc bien
que les consomme pas parce que les mois
2 tentation consommation donc on est
confiné que la plupart des magasins sont
fermés on consomme moins bon ce qui
n'est pas régulé forcé merci vous
connais pas de précaution de gens qui
ont peur de l'avenir de tarbes 2 par
l'emploi de deux paires de peur de
l'entreprise faire de peur de l'avenir
de nos confinement et donc nous devons
lutter contre cette absence de confiance
et je pense que personnellement le grand
problème que les connaissons aujourd'hui
c'est pas de service qu'ils assurent une
fiscalisation savane de confiance
remettre les entrepreneurs dans le côté
de ceux qui investissent remettre aux
investisseurs du côté de ceux qui font
confiance à notre pays et remettre les
amateurs du côté de la consommation est
battu quelle mesure peut-on prendre moi
je ne pense pas que ce cadeau fiscal qui
nous forcer les gens à consommer ça a
montré son peu d'efficacité nous devons
montrer aux français
notre entreprise qui peut avoir de
nouveau confiance dans l'économie du
pays et peut il doit continuer à être
marché du mobilier qui doivent continuer
à investir qu'il a continué à consommer
on avait le même problème alors un peu
moins quatre fils aymon temps aux
membres de la crise et j'y vais je les
annoncerai par le gouvernement où
étaient les annonceurs
pour m droits d'achat des français il ya
plusieurs mois
les augmentations de pouvoir d'achat je
pense qu'elle ne s'est pas traduit dans
une dérogation forcément mal
consommation et d'une augmentation des
parle comme s'il ne croyait pas que les
impôts avec autres blessés et comme s'il
ne croyait pas que les normands allaient
continuer travailler près des gens et
puis un second mois de blocage et nous
avons connu des recettes fiscales très
importante sur la tva notamment
donc je pense que donc toujours
l'économie et n'est pas une science dure
sur ce comportement tel est le nombre d
confiance ça passe notamment par le fait
que nous répéterons et je répète que le
soft sera le gouvernement est celle que
je porte au sein du gouvernement ajoute
ce n'est pas d'augmentation d'impôts
voilà et ce n'est pas le décalage de
prix des baisses d'impôts qui était peu
on amènera peut-être que tout à l'heure
je m'appelle comme ça aussi avec
question sur la thèse de la tâche la
base des recettes fiscales grâce à cette
occasion de répondre à la fois à vous
même ce qu'est né sur quoi il ya du sud
pour évoquer des collectivités locales
je sais que ce à travers son spectateur
gérer première monte les collectivités
locales vous connaître dans un temps
court pour une partie d'entre elles et
2021 une plus grande partie d'entre
elles des difficultés qui sont liées à
l'or baisse de recettes
cependant 70% des recettes des
collectivités locales c'est évidemment
très mal aux économies que ce que je dis
et les différents centres communaux en
continu collectivités leurs recettes ne
sont pas niés ou à l'activité économique
taxe d'habitation même la taxe foncière
les dotations d'état ne sont pas liées à
l'activité économique
paupières 70 % de leurs recettes ne
voudra pas 30% des recettes vont bouger
bienvenue parmi ses recettes il ya
plusieurs types de collectivités
il ya celles dont on a assuré par
rapport au chaînon la loi sur l'aide pas
rapproché de fait ne descendra pas en
dessous au billboard
par exemple pour la tva pour les régions
j'ai une référence que c'est de laver
2007 et 11 même si la tva c'est paul
absolument les régions sont assurés
d'obtenir accroché par exemple dans la
réforme de la taxe d'habitation bien à
plancher nous n'avons même négocieront
tendu le sur ce point pour qu' il ya une
référence c'est d'ailleurs ce qui me
fait dire que
heureusement qu'à la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation les peaux demain les
départements vont toucher plus tôt de la
tva pour la taxe foncière sur le foncier
bâti passe que lui par sensible si dans
deux trois ans quand tu auras s'il y en
a des failles et économiquement moins
d'entreprises opérant sur le territoire
et c'est souvent l'état et par les plus
pauvres qui augment de recettes fiscales
et par ailleurs vous aurez constaté que
deux mois contre ce plancher on discuté
assez longuement ici va permettre
d'avoir des recettes qui malgré douze
seront assurées sans augmenter les taux
parce que selon les départements et
notamment les plus pauvres jusque là
territoire qu'on pourrait qualifier de
pauvres augmente les taux de ceux qui
restent et donc diminue encore plus la
compétitivité de l'économie territoriale
sans régler les problèmes sociaux
puisque près département les greens
spéciale se pose évidemment en même
temps que celle de leurs ancêtres et en
troisième en valorisant les départements
les plus riches qui veut pour la
possibilité d'avoir plus de matelas son
côté cette expression pour revenir sur
ces questions de recettes
lb c'est ce sur quoi nous travaillons et
c'était pas un arbitrage mais je me dois
de répondre honnêtement à la question
que vous posez c'est plutôt une
compensation des recettes perdues que
des dépenses engagées demain à des
exceptions bien évidemment vous aurez
bien compris que ce sont les masques par
exemple existe une décision 50/50
d'aider les collectivités et le cachet
des races mais sur les recettes et nous
avons missionné le député cazeneuve qui
voit dans quelques semaines rendre son
rapport à la ministre moreau et à moi
même sous l'autorité du corps du
ministre
nous sommes en train d'imaginer alors
même que rien de l'audit et que
l'autonomie financière souvent appelé
par les parlementaires doit être
respectée et plus conformes encore
public mars car nous pensons que nous
pouvons compenser une partie des
recettes qui n'est pas prévue par la loi
en exemple des droits de mutation et la
mutation bombay point d'effondrement
très fort parce qu'on voit bien qu'il
n'ya pas de lobby en ce moment il n'aura
pas de suite demain les départements
bien sûr les communes intercommunalités
aussi pour avoir une baisse très forte
urbanisation sans doute faut-il que le
gouverneur aurait le spyware 2009
personne n'a fait ça
personne n'a compensé les recettes des
collectivités locales qui avait été
perdu dans l'attaqué deux de pointe
nous réfléchissons la possibilité de
compenser et de proposer au parlement de
compenser
une partie de ces recettes qu'elle est
une référence qu'il faut faire sur
plusieurs années c'est un débat encore à
voir avec les collectivités locales que
je vais unis souvent ministre bureau
mais c'est plutôt le contre quel droit
de ce point de vue monsieur moi je ne
suis pas favorable aux petites ou alors
pas du tout du tout à inscrire toutes
les dépenses des collectivités en sorte
de passe passe comptable malgré tout
dans l'investissement on va paraître le
jem et doit le politologue vestissement
on va pas mettre le salaire des agents
que les collectivités le cateau
viendrait à embaucher pour mettre la
distanciation possible dans les cantines
en investissement alors la section
investissement la section embauchant à
ne plus rien dire et qu'est ce qui se
passe quand on fait ça on le début on
est un peu content parce que la vérité
c'est que l'on sait de la marge pour
pouvoir les 600 photos du fonctionnement
doit emprunter
enfin on va avoir un problème d'ordre 2
3 4 ou 5 ans notamment avec les agences
de notation qui va régler les
collectivités locales et la grande
collectivité locale permettent d'avoir
un peu marrant j'ai les combes si j'ose
dire parce que éloquence l'avons
d'ailleurs autorisé la subvention versée
c'est une exception à la règle que je
devais dire notamment dans le son de
l'indemnisation pour les régions et
toutes les petites collectivités
ce ne sera pas possible parce que j'ai
pas d'argent magic s'est plaint de
l'emprunt on va nous dire est que la
plus tard nous préférons travailler sur
d'une part la compensation d'une partie
des recettes des collectivités
demain le 1er bis a peut-être une
annonce sur les collectivités
touristique
c'est le cas des hippodromes c'est le
conte des taxes de séjour qui est très
importante dans leur fonctionnement
c'est pas le cas je le regrette à tours
poids maxi ceinture c'est sûr que c'est
plus compliqué la ville a fait quant à
biarritz et à bonifacio c'est une
évidence et les tailles de séjour qui
s'effondre c'est pire à l'innovation des
turquoises absolument vrai il faut
peut-être puisque sur ce point et puis
deuxièmement sur la discussion montage
nous allons proposer aux collectivités
locales nationales et qui semble
l'accepter soit de très rares budgets
annexes qui ramènerait les dépenses
fonctionnement reste solide et bien
pouvoir les identifier
sophie raconte didier kelly l'équivalent
du budget annexe en plus simple et qui
permet notamment aux petites
collectivités ne pas créer la gênerait
compliquée du budget annexe à 6 14 ans
d'études en tout cas notre consensus en
ce moment ce couac des associations
d'élus sur ce point et je voudrais
remercier dans l'esprit dans lequel
à bâle nord est un des dix plus gros
bassins gta prolongement des primes ce
qui me suit président mais comme ça j'ai
créé ce vote rassemblés sur le casse
pension j'ai pas donné de l'église n'est
pas oublier bien évidemment et je le
serai très rapidement sur la polynésie
vos amis polynésiens en raison de se
poser des questions alors de soucis la
république jeudi précédent fritsch et
jeudi aux parlementaires que vous
représentez par la voix la question de
creuser ce n'est pas de laisser tomber
évidemment les gouvernement autonome du
pacifique d'ailleurs nous ne l'avons pas
fait pour la nouvelle calédonie puisque
nous avons fait et vous l'avez vu opl fr
numéro 2 des aides d'emprunt de plus
près notamment par allah et ça a
beaucoup aidé le plan note qu'elle est
devenue cependant nous devons aussi
respecter l'autre demie de ces
territoires du pacifique et notamment
autour des questions sociales relève de
l'intégralité des souverainetés des
guillemets du gouvernement polynésie et
nous avons offert au président de fitch
la possibilité de faire effectivement
encore albert qu'elle est de 10 et
d'avoir des prêts qui garantissent
l'autonomie de compétences évidemment de
la politique française et qui permet
d'avoir une solidarité nationale avec
sniper qui évidemment est aussi touchée
par les questions plaisait beaucoup
même si dans le cas de la polynésie
comme le cas d'un métier 2008 à mon
après midi des réformes sociales sont
aussi des entreprises par les
gouvernements
il faut saluer dans le courage du
président fritsch et de son équipe à la
tête de la police
et donc oui madame la sénatrice le
gouvernement a proposé est acceptable
on a encore discuté un petit peu dans
lequel fr numéro 3 une aide à peu près
similaire mutatis mutandis à ce qui
existe admettre que l'ennemi est donc si
nous continuons à aboutir quelques jours
pour discussion constructive et
responsable présente évidemment nous
serons aux côtés des polynésiens bien
évidemment monsieur bazin a posé la
question d'après une activité alors en
s'étonnant de la soviétisation faire
constater qu'on est quasiment
écumant la lumière est retrouvé à
quelques centaines de millions après on
n'est quand même pas tout assez loin de
la vérité dire à monsieur bazin et que
la vérité c'est qu'un reprise économique
est récente en 2019 beaucoup plus forte
que les prévisions même dans neuf ans et
qu'après une activité c'est quelque
chose qui se touchent trop 05 4 smic et
peugeot qui a tenu cette automatique
désormais c'est plus une demande avec un
taux de neubourg qui existait au parc
ans et ça correspond exactement à la
promesse du présente dans la clinique
200 euros de plus au smic pour un
travailleur qui reprend le travail est
donc effectivement c'est millions
d'euros supplémentaires n'ont pas été
tous d'exécution sous-évaluation parlons
du gouvernement mais correspond au
regard de la reprise de l'emploi de
l'époque et chacun voit qu'ils aient eu
une baisse très importante du chômage
dans l'académisme
voilà pourquoi le travailleur qui
reprend un travail avait plus de
dépenses les sénateurs pour légitimement
s'interroger c'est celle qui consiste à
voir à la baisse le support social
oddo reprend un travail mois d'assurance
le chômage et plus de dépenses sociales
parce que c'est une prestation sociale
la prime est imité qui est logé dans le
week end chez les rangs et pas dans
l'origine d'un hélico 41 des beatles
prestations sociales donnés par le cast
de toutes ces raisons de l'évoquer et on
a augmenté le nombre de tp dans le cadre
il ya quelque chose par contre 2002 dire
à le chômage baisse vraiment passé
sociale mais en fait ils dévorent
socialement parce que la connectivité
qui va car près du travail mais en même
temps c'est une façon d'aider évidemment
ceux qui travaillent par rapport à ceux
qui nous lisent pas
vous avez évoqué la question de n'est
pas très compliqué question monsieur le
monsieur le sénateur je pourrai pas m'y
attarder ne serait-ce que peut-être
tueur à gages aux constatations
c'est le budget qui fait effectivement
la moindre reprise d'activité par des
gens qui étaient au chômage et il
retombe à l'emploi c'est des tribunes
je suis pas capable de vous dire
aujourd'hui peut-être leur avant-poste
un peu plus d'éléments sur les montants
ni sur la productivité je rappellerai la
connectivité passé 3 milliards et
quasiment 10 en l'espace de trois ans ce
qu'est une question quand même
intéressant
vous avez évoqué la question d'appel
social en disant peut-être 880 millions
d'euros nécessaires à ces je ne sais pas
je ne peux pas encore le dire exactement
ce qui est sûr c'est que nous avons
prévu un milliard c'est encore dans les
dépenses imprévisible et accidentelle
article 7 de la love que vous y avez eu
la gentillesse de vouloir accepter tant
les contrôlant parce que je dois rendre
un rapport le quasi hebdomadaire alo
presidente commission des finances alors
demandé c'est bien légitime et donc nous
avons les moyens de mettre les crédits
s'il devait manquer sans évoquer les
faits récents défense devant les primes
et ont évoqué sur les fonds européens
je n'ai pas la réponse entre elles mais
je veux bien apprendre à pêcher à la
mouche l'un d'eux vous d'affaires
parvenir bien évidemment le ministre
karoutchi faut remercier d'avoir salué
le taux de jeunes à avoir entre deux
souriantes
je ne le vois pas ce cap et là d'un
évoque la question de l'efficacité des
mesures légion il appartient sans doute
au parlement d'évaluer le seul ministre
l'action gouvernementale mais moi je
parle que les choses parfois décidé vous
l'avez dit avec rapidité
d'abord a été exécuté avec une dextérité
par l'administration française est
régulièrement parcelles question de
l'autorité mais aussi a permis
d'améliorer le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens notamment de ceux qui
travaillent prenons deux exemples 100
euros d'augmentation smic a été fait
immédiatement et je crois que c'est des
saluts et ça se traduit budgétairement
les gens ont du travail il y a plus
intérêt à te régales pas travailler ça
doit vous rappeler le je crois un peu
d'histoire politique commune de monsieur
monsieur ministre et d'autre part la
presse de la poste venu avec merci
d'avoir posé aucune question clairement
sur l'appellation parce que les droits
de l'homme ici finalement et de
nouvelles serait candidate
un apport au point qu effectivement
l'une des recettes supplémentaires sont
d'augmenter les impôts 1 attention de
revenus à partir du 20 janvier de cette
année être aujourd'hui les pros citoyen
lui impuissant d'état venus à payer
moins deux mois de fiscalité surtout
lorsqu'ils travaillent puissent poser
des coups précis des deux premières
entre je crois qu'à mesure que les gones
ont réellement
démontré leur efficacité voilà l'ancien
évidemment gouvernement de produire les
rapports qui compteront parlement de
débuter sur l'audiovisuel public
bon je n'ai pas m'entendre discussions
monsieur karoutchi qui m'a valu quelques
soucis mais je reste persuadé que ma
conviction est la bonne c'est à dire la
façon dont aujourd'hui les financer
l'audiovisuel public de correspond plus
exactement à la façon dont je vais
passer lancé il ya 15 20 ou 30 ans qui
était une très bonne façon de faire a
ajouté auprès de comment supprimer la
taxe d'habitation nous avoir mon adresse
cette redevance est que la plupart de
gens de ma génération mais je suis sûr
de la vôtre également ministre regarde
la télévision
outtara tour autrement qu'avec applaudir
et télévision une fois que j'ai dit ça
j'ai pas l'impression d'avoir été
particulièrement révolutionnaire mais je
comprends ce que les questions qu'il
faut continuer à poser mai 2010 et la
culture y travaille tous les noms
évidemment et peut-être que les
comparaisons internationales vont nous
aider à aider le secteur public a bien
fonctionné les économies n'existe plus
visuelle que chic et se fait 50 millions
après semble-t-il par an bouddhiste
himalayen du mal à faire des économies
dans ce moment je crois que nous les
responsabilités de notre rapport ce qui
est certain c'est que je constate que
dans les chaînes privées il ya moins de
recettes publicitaires alors qu'elle
devance extrêmement humble et que je
crois que des plans d'économies ce qu'on
fait j'ai confiance dans les
responsables de france télévisions la
défense corrobore commandes et je crois
qu'ils ne sont je crois qu'il se trompe
et je laisserais votre rapport de dire
attentivement et nous la culture
avant ça la question de la redevance et
devait encore se ne se poser monsieur
gainey a évoqué beaucoup de ressources
plus répondu mais location je n'ai pas
pu faire il a posé la question des
dégâts l'adcp d'appeler chacun des rôles
grève
ouahbi en plus on sera dessiné sur la
terre
en quoi c'est compliqué objectivement
aujourd'hui de savoir comment les
cheveux modeler penser une chose votre
ajouté mais je ne sais pas très bien ces
questions électorales de se refermer
très bon investissement
et les ânes électorale où les élections
entre patio de se tenir à des dates 6 me
dire ce encore moins bonne la décision
prise par le président a répliqué
commune il autorisé après l'avis du
conseil scientifique la réunion en
trente mille comic con est élu au
premier tour derrière leur maire
d'internet je crois de débloquer à sa
tombe du sujet de l'investissement
contre elle et les rallumer tous mais il
n'ya pas que la crise qui explique les
difficultés des investissements
l'utilisation de ces consommations
investissements et ainsi des indes
électorale et malheureusement on n'avait
pas totalement décalé et parfois conduit
pour les responsables des responsables
et municipaux chacun peut le comprendre
donc escurat liberté d'ailleurs deux des
oppressés pour laquelle je n'ai pas
autorité sur les préfets pour cette
question des dotations d'investissement
qui relève exclusivement des mots et
d'émotions le corps nu mais j'ai cru
comprendre de monsieur le candu qui
s'est exprimée plusieurs fois pour dire
que vous garderez l' enveloppe globale
et construit très souple pour personne
le plus rapidement possible consommer
quitte à ce que les préfets puissent
effectivement accompagné des choses qui
n'étaient pas prévues
vonlanthen je les lis ça je pense que
j'ai compris qu effectivement les
ministres qui sont tous les deux des
élus locaux on voit bien un intérêt de
laisser de liberté elle par yann je
rappelle d'ailleurs que normalement les
parlementaires doivent être associés à
ces décisions sur la bio terre ici parce
que deux souhaits du gouvernement une
formation peut rappeler mais je sais que
vous êtes sans doute garonne le cas à
l'autre avant de préciser en question a
été abordée en se gagner sur les
collectivités qui avait demandé des
avants de fiscalité à ma connaissance il
y en a inventé une qui se sont exprimé
auprès de la direction générale des
finances publiques
elle peut surprendre 6007 un chiffre
acceptable et pour 18 millions de
demandes d' avance de fiscalité j'ai
autorisé d avance avec les ministres en
charge de la dgcl et qu'un autre
dotation de meilleur des problèmes il
n'y a pas encore eu le sujet le constate
d'ailleurs on a quasiment 50 milliards
de trésorerie pour les collectivités
locales
au moment où je vous parle c'est un
trésorerie importante et que ceux qui
regardent encore ce qui se passe dans
leur commune d'élections naturelles ont
vu que les deuxièmes de fiscalité ont
été percés à l'heure et donc l'état n'a
passé de cavalerie
causerie des collectivités locales
encore un swing soleil fctva est
finalement là le sujet de la reprise les
deux l'idée de président sarkozy qu'elle
est bien marché en 2009 je rappelle que
des conseils municipaux toute autre
collectivité de prendre une délibération
pour utiliser cela ça peut être
intéressant s'est demandé notamment par
la haye mais nous sommes prêts à étudier
notamment dans le cas d'une forme de
résidences du plan de relance
c'est quand même 6 milliards
l'imputation budgétaire mais c'est vrai
que ça aide
la fiscalité locale sans doute pas cette
année je pense que vous refuserez parce
que comme ils ont déjà pas encore
consommée dans dotations
d'investissement enfin discussions
précédentes c'était pas la peine de
rajouter cette saga halo chose peut-être
pour 2021 qu'il serait sans doute une
année où les élus seront pas première
fois réélu avec une année pleine et ça
tu as l'occasion de mettre un peu
d'argent dans la boutique
à ceci près que il faut savoir que ça a
plié un coup ça vous avez fait ça
évidemment pas forcément quelque chose
qu'ils seront prêts à chaque année
d'ailleurs c'est parce qu'ils étaient
séparés glement passé non mais pourquoi
pas et on y travaille et son tourment
rien à cause des fuites
les avants de production est-ce que
c'est pas me laisser tranquille des
collectivités locales
je pourrais vous répondre ce que c'est
un moment d'aider les entreprises à
assurer une production ils sont payés
qui à part la c3s qui paient la sécu
sont payés aux collectivités au théâtre
j'ai bien compris que le président
varois notamment à une ligne rouge et a
évoqué plusieurs fois écrit une liste
remise de l'économie mais aussi une
quelque chose à l'introduction voilà les
mains sont où les décisions sont entre
les mains du président de la république
je crois que déjà dit plusieurs fois
parce que la production grève et la
compétitivité de nos entreprises et
notamment dans les territoires les plus
industriels et des paroles il imposa
c'est absurde et on réalise et le coup
la fabrication au moment où le
relocaliser notre pays il m'apparaît
assez contradictoire de vouloir pas de
clichés cette imposition et bois
absolument tout le monde revient
fabriquer des masques les médicaments et
les plus produits notre taille pas vaste
choix de politique économique
mais ne m'appartient pas de rendre les
arbitrages qui n'ont pas été rendus nos
semelles d'établir une question
d'intérêt monsieur carcenac avait
demandé si j'étais d'accord avec
monsieur subit souvent d'ailleurs qu'il
avait été conseiller du président
sarkozy
je l'entends il m'arrive d'avoir des
désaccords à lépine ancien conseiller du
président sarkozy
moi je ne suis pas favorable à la sueur
fiscalité et je suis d'ailleurs pas
favorable à monsieur personnages les
déloger fiscal isf je sais ce que ça
donne dans la région
la fuite des gens cave et du capital
dans d'autres pays boos deux côtés de la
frontière
il nous a gardés le chômage et d'autres
pays ont pris la richesse je répète les
pompes par je ne suis pas favorable à un
impôt sur le capital le président de la
république a eu l'occasion d'avoir ce
courage de supprimer au formellement sa
campagne présidentielle
ce que n'ont pas fait ma famille
politique auparavant et elle regretté
c'est à pau à tout moment idéologique
que personne n'ose à copier si je ne
vais pas faire le brevet sur le sujet la
création
je constate d'ailleurs que quand on
évoquait juillet de recette n'avait pas
à relever mais ces deux milliards 8
les recettes supplémentaires par rapport
au ps prévu de 2019 sur l'augmentation
de l'ifi en recettes et sur
l'augmentation du pfc quand même
intéressant plus aux baisses d'impôts tu
en as de recettes
manifestement sur ces sujets un
gouvernement en dommages l'occasion de
dire à sens unique
un peu idéologique aura l'occasion de
remettre du tss si jamais il ne souhaite
augmenter le père fut un rendement va
être super beau père et je prends mon
pareil qu'au bout de deux ans parce
qu'évidemment nous sommes pas dans un
monde chargé donc je ne suis pas
favorable et le redis à l'impôt sur la
fortune de nouvelles formules de même
améliorée vous avez évoqué immobilier de
l'état
je rappellerai que nous avons beaucoup
misé déjà d'argent sur ce point
notamment sur les sites et
administrative puisque j'ai eu
l'occasion d'annoncer beaucoup d'une
construction d'hôtels administratif pour
améliorer la vie des agents vont faire
des choses et économe en terme de
le d'environnement ma région par exemple
connaît un petit bec système strativa
gilde healthcare amiens je vais signer
dans quelques heures la cité
administrative de lyon
j'écoute dire que le maire de nancy pour
éviter sa stratégie j'étais le gars
également dans les territoires du sud de
notre pays
donc nous faisons des bourgeons des
merci d'y participer avec d'autres dans
ce conseil de l'immobilier quand les
remarques de la cour des comptes s'était
juste et donc nous avons repensé ce qui
était nécessaire et j'ai demandé au
nouveau directeur de l'immobilier de
l'état sur est candidat n'a été nommé
récemment de pouvoir appliquer les
rapports de la cour je n'ai pas
connaissance monsieur personnage de
difficultés de recrutement pour la
l'équipe de la nation piste soit data
mailing
ils sont une trentaine aujourd'hui ça
correspond exactement à ce qui était
prévenue ayant devrait constater que
dans le budget des nih pas nous avons à
la fois augmenter les effectifs et les
crédits sur ce sujet je pense que
l'équipe est l'occasion d'évoquer des
questions étaient notés sur le de force
tout à l'heure je le veux venir je viens
d'évoquer la prestation du stade auquel
a d'ailleurs participé à ce que la cecab
les gens merci de tes sa contribution
on n'a pas changé les critères et on a
bien eu à peu près 48 millions d'euros
pour son projet et nous partons toujours
du principe qu'il faut évidemment ça des
économies déficiences quatre nouveaux
projets pour l'emploi ale vous les
connaissez sans doute a fait des projets
très intéressants et améliorer les
services publics et qui permet de moins
dépenser d'argent
je pense que c'est ce que nous venons ce
maginez monsieur raynal a évoqué la
question de la position je vais pas
revenir à monsieur car c'est mal mais je
ne partage pas son idée que quand un
problème faut créer un impôt sur les
collectivités locales
je crois avoir beaucoup et produit une
question va me dire ce que j'ai pu faire
tout à l'heure et sur les libertés décès
au préfet je vous accuse également
répondu premières peintures son analyse
parfois préhistorique d'erevan de qui de
monsieur sarkozy mais selon des plus de
problèmes ne sont pas venus je sais que
ça qui est lancinant puisque j'ai sera
pas
nécessaire à chacun mais c'est
impensable sans doute le candidat n'a
pas pu se présenter sur les questions de
votre dernier qui sont assez mais comme
d'habitude très spécialisés logement les
frais que je suis à ma connaissance 433
millions en 2019 à 339 millions en 2018
et ça inclus dans le calcul puisque
c'est sa question la dette
ce matin donc je parle qu'on pourrait
puisqu'il est spécialisée question et
qui n'a pas trouvé la réponse et quand
il pose la question c'est que maintenant
ça n'est pas écrite préciser les choses
peut-être dans les prochains documents
budgétaires
je crois que exactement il a raison de
le demander sauf régie de gestion des
appels
j'avoue ne pas connaître avec précision
la réponse mais s'il me le permet je ne
viendrais serait la réponse de monsieur
normandie de chez de l'économie que nous
confirme après des buts contre 8,8 est
reporté de nouveau sur l'écologie je
comprends bien les personnes de
solutions mais j'ai du mal à suivre son
raisonnement consisterait à penser qu'on
était des économies budgétaires sur les
prix une conversion je crois monsieur
leçon que les documents budgétaires
alors 5e lecture le démon ce que vous
avez tort il y a élu un dispositif qui a
très bien marché
est-ce qu'il a trop bien marché par
rapport aux applications comptables
manifestement puisque par ailleurs le
rappelle il fallait vraiment prendre une
disposition législative pour mettre de
l'avant
nous avons continué à mettre de l'argent
beaucoup plus que prévu dans le budget
des ménages beaucoup plus que prévu a
fait aucune économie dans les chiffres
constatés les conversions simplement il
a fallu effectivement dire aider autant
ceux qui le souhaitent auprès des
concessionnaires parce que ma formation
est ce qu on n'a peut-être pas été assez
ambitieux projet trop bien c'est la
rochefoucauld nous faire il n'y a pas
d'économies budgétaires sur le ministère
de l'écologie et le risque écologique
il est même en augmentation la plus
importante depuis la création sous la
présidence de giscard d'estaing il n'y a
pas d'augmentation s'ils veulent rendre
si l'on pense que la petite boutique
ces mesures à l'argent comines et dans
le ministère de l'écologie et au
ministère des transports et des
transitions sur lubrizol maïs et des bas
notamment
les collègues de son métier du groupe
communiste je crois que ce n'est pas un
des sous me semble-t-il budgétaire comme
brise elle est arrivée ou deux autres
catastrophes de ce type arrive on a eu
l'occasion de te dégoûter je ne
reviendrai pas d'installer de l'écologie
sans vous sera contre l'efficacité des
politiques publiques alors que
comprendre qu'il est comme beaucoup de
français je vais là-bas chez monsieur
visez vous poser une question quasi moi
c'est bénéfique sur l'avenir de l'euro
tu vas t'on et certains sont pas en
guerre avec l'application des lois de
règlement mais je sais que répondre
quand même parce que peut-être n'est-il
pas là mais vous l'avez évoqué le show
de sénateurs puisqu'il tient l'édition
du soir masse à l'heure c'est le roux
quand même et je pense qu'il faudrait le
répéter qui nous a protégés d'être
attaquée sur les marchés financiers
pensent crise on ne va pas refaire le
fait part de volumes imaginez si
napoléon était né sur le spi c'est ce
qu'il aurait encore de français ou pas
si on évalue l'euro se sont quand même
intéressant d'écrire l'histoire
je pense que l'on aurait été attaquée
dès qu'on aurait été de les libérer
voilà on aurait un problème très
important dans la pâte jusqu'à présent
donc d'abord l'euro en toute chose a été
positive positif cette monnaie tôt face
aux difficultés c'est bien notre
convergence avec l'allemagne qui nous
permettent est ce que les différences de
fiscalité
ils ne sont pas de belles et c'est pour
ça qu'on veut baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés pourrait s'être ouvert un impôt
européen qui s'est passé d un bts que
les différences de politiques de relance
est ce que les différences de politiques
sociales vont faire que mono moment le
haut dégustera plus haut va éclater nos
divergences de politiques publiques soit
pas porte à risque et à la fin de la
réponse européenne qui est en train
d'être mis en place
d'abord la décennie le cas travail
formidable sous la pression des états
d'amérique et la france appelait sa part
et demain dans le condroz lance je suis
breton aura l'occasion dans quelques
heures ou dans quelques jours d'annoncer
que monsieur répète c'est un grand club
med au tourisme c'est une très bonne
chose pour l'ensemble de l'europe et
singulièrement pour la france a dit par
la réponse de l'éclatement ou pas de
zone euro qui sont un danger absolu et
notre pas il appartient de postiga
discuter bien évidemment à nos amis
allemands
par contre on doit avoir une politique
budgétaire fiscale à peu près similaire
en tout cas avec des différences ne soit
pas fait grande vitesse et des cas je
vois devises l économie des finances et
du peso notre mission nous sommes ici
l'hôtel de l'assemblée de dire que
effectivement lorsque l'italie mais 2%
de son pib dans la relance et que
l'allemagne les 4,4 de son pib notre
soutien de son économie alors ça devrait
être la verse des difficultés comme des
pays
des questions se posent le joie que de
voir des européens se faire pour que
cette grande monnaie c'est une
construction qui nous attendent et en
protection nestos par se posera son sexe
et son âge est évidemment est terminée
par marc cherry abouti soit et ex
affectés je ne sais pas s'il est entendu
mon introduction donc techniquement moi
aussi et comme la mode et contre me
plairait commission des finances n'a
posé la question
la multiplication des taxes affectées et
il a bien raison des cas sans doute
parce que encore une fois les français
sont très actifs alors pour les copains
de plus très bien où cela nous sans
doute à vanter de l'eau entraînant un
effet les plus pédagogique le sport qui
paye de sport la route qui paye la route
et on voit bien que ça ses limites et
ses polémiques
nous sommes favorables les manière
générale la simplification en tout cas
mais les écoles publiques et je crois
que nous c'était comme des prédécesseurs
et 75 successeurs seront favorables à ça
alors on a essayé de le faire parfois on
l'a fait parfois votre soutien parfois
et votre résistance qu'à la suppression
des taxes
c'est une forme de simplification de
supprimer une quinzaine de petits textes
chaque année mais bon taxes affectées
plus de budgétisation faut-il faire
quelque chose de plus large
le rapporteur général de l'assemblée
nationale a déposé une proposition de
loi organique visant à changer le
fonctionnement du budget d'état la drôme
ou l'a9 finalement je travaille par
ailleurs à l'amélioration des débats
parlementaires et à la simplification ou
à l'amélioration de leur côté dark des
temps de réfléchir à améliorer dans
l'oeuf nous a rendu de grands services
numériques comme quelque chose votre
revenu
nous seront favorables en tout cas le
ministre des comptes publics sera
favorable à toute simplification proposé
par le parlement ils veulent même avoir
décidé lui-même pour simplifier au
maximum
peut-être pas toutes au maximum les et
les comptes spéciaux les taxes affûté et
les font déjà leur étau sur ce point la
cour des comptes
évidemment a raison de demander plus de
simplification